[Music]
and time to be honest news
stop lying to be honest submit it by sam
i am green eggs and ham oh wait that's
where this is from
dr seuss girl i said it in my head as
you said that's cute
um tinder's new height verification
system is costing us
a stir amongst men bruh that's [ __ ]
fun so
stupid and so good because back in my
day
i used to be on tinder and dude every
guy on tinder is like six
eight every guy on tv six five six
seven six eight like you're like where
are these men in real life
even guys with guys are [ __ ] weird
dude um
like i'm not sure if this well i'm six
one okay
like for real has it been verified by
tinder i'm a doctor
six months six one in the morning when
it gets night time six feet
so my [ __ ] spine compresses but guys
are so [ __ ] weird i'm six one i know
my height right and
whatever six one six feet it doesn't
[ __ ] matter to me yeah literally had
conversations with dudes where they go
oh yeah like i'm six one and they're
like two inches shorter dude
you're not six one dude i'm six one you
cannot he goes no you must be like six
four
you can't up my height to make you feel
taller dude i hate that
[ __ ] yeah bro you're like six seven or
something what are you like a nba player
like shut the [ __ ] up dude like you're
you're five
ten i'm five ten yes so one time at the
gym um i was just like minding my
business at la fitness with my
headphones on
and this guy comes up to me like i had
just put the bar away and he looks at me
and he's like
and i was like i took my [ __ ]
headphone out and i was like yes
he's like how tall are you like six feet
and i was like 5 10. i already was
putting my headphone back in
and he's like i'm 5 10 and i'm like
[ __ ] bye like i don't have time
time to prove your masculinity right now
you know what i mean like
i'm 5 10 no you are not you are not like
that just means he was ugly because if
he was hot you'd be like oh
i could see that right no no i mean
first i have a boyfriend i don't care
that she would have changed real quick
say yeah you [ __ ] ten you got damn you
fought 10. you bought 10 and all that oh
[ __ ] you might be 60
you start [ __ ] scratching down a
little bit too you [ __ ] it
i really tried like i tried it and it
didn't work out for me you know um but i
just like i think a confident man
regardless of height would be dope you
know what i mean but when you approach a
woman
trying to be like oh you're shorter than
like his dick just got this big yeah
like
[ __ ] if i was 5 10 and you're 5 8 like
it could work but you're out here
reaching you know what i mean like why
are you trying to lie on people
tim's a good example of that tim i
always think he's taller than he
actually is yeah yeah
because he has such a even joe and he
never even oh dude
just a good one and they'll they'll
never ask how tall someone is
right it doesn't even matter right yeah
unlike some people
like uh case and jen like that guy is
always asking
everyone how tall they are oh huh jason
chen
oh oh you called him out dad that's
[ __ ] up
i coded his name i was like who is it
yeah you got to be smart with it
that [ __ ] was next level bro that went
right over my [ __ ] head that's how
you know i'm [ __ ] married to this
no that means you're a genius okay yeah
jason's so [ __ ] funny dude jason's
like what five foot one
he's always taking pictures with because
his girlfriend's a little bit taller i
think i know where they are i found them
on the explore page every time you meet
someone like he's always like
wait am i talking he always wants to
take pictures with me to show how like
the height
this one just has rulers in his eyes
like everybody's going
i love you jason you're all right jason
it's almost his girlfriend like she's
like two inches taller
oh she looks taller you know and she's
skinny so she's like looks long and
elegant
yeah so tinder that's [ __ ] funny
so that they're gonna have this height
verification badge
that is a good idea i'm with it so let
me show you
i already know what guys are gonna say
too like where's the girls where's the
girls makeup verification yeah
they should have that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i feel like i feel like i want them to
to continue to lie though like i don't
care for the hype versus what you just
showed us the logo wouldn't even even
seem like
i'm talking i wanted to show the video
but she's talking okay um
i was like just a logo he's used to
hearing the [ __ ] peepee
he tuned me up i didn't turn you off no
but i don't mind that they don't have a
high verification because yeah you're
gonna be disappointed when you first see
them or whatever right but then i'm like
you're a [ __ ] liar ass for sure we're
not gonna date you know what they should
also do though
they should do an angle verification
yeah i've seen [ __ ]
[ __ ] let me tell you something
who the [ __ ] takes a photo from the back
of their head [ __ ]
you better put that [ __ ] right here dude
it's like look at you today [ __ ]
put it right here that's where i want to
see it they should also do a job
verification back oh yeah that too he
had a job
this is very you know what actually
though there are apps outside of tinder
where you have to be a certain level of
professional to even join so they
actually screen you
that's nice like the millionaire
matchmaker kind of people it kind of
like that but not that high
it's uh like i have a friend's couple
friends who are doctors and they do that
instead oh they want to meet other
i think i would do that like if we were
to break up like that wouldn't happen
yeah yeah um if we would ever break up i
would want to pay for a subscription
because i feel like i'd weed out all the
[ __ ]
imagine like okay let's because i do
know like there's like certain ones you
have to have like a degree for you have
to make this much money for
like imagine how many people you might
be ruling out that might be great
but they're not on my level damn so your
level is like monetary
uh well or education so i i would want
someone to have some sort of education
and the only one i can
yeah so the one that i can quantify is a
degree right because i'll be like at
least i can have this
type of conversation and they'll
understand these vocabulary words right
but i mean there's so many i mean i
don't or someone that's hustled that
hard before did you guys watch free solo
no like the dude that climbed that
[ __ ] serial killer
i don't know if he's college educated i
don't know if he's balling or not but
the amount of grind and hustle that
you've had to have
to accomplish i'll tell you about that
guy though if he's not climbing
mountains he's killing people and racism
he is a [ __ ] cycle because he did the
mcat scan right yeah
they're looking a little different dude
when i was watching they're literally
trying to check if there's something
wrong with his brain to see if he's a
normal human being
and then he's like well if my girlfriend
died then
that's that's just what it is you know
and he goes well if i die you shouldn't
care either because
you know you'll move on what did he do
what's his accomplishment he reclined
in yosemite it's like one of the tallest
ones that everyone occurs
yeah so like everyone has free solo
which means rock climbing without a
harness or belt
so the minute you slip and you fall
you're done you're dead
and then they're and these holes are
still going like
they still grab off to some other ship
so uh everyone's climbed up to like this
height i don't know like 900 feet or
whatever and
he's attempting 3 000. he went up like a
few [ __ ] miles up he's such a [ __ ]
psychopath
after he completed that [ __ ] but i think
only one other person did
he he does that so [ __ ] often at the
end of the dock he just climbed it he's
still practicing his grip in his van
like still practicing his like after he
just climbed four [ __ ] miles up into
the like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
yeah and then they they show that every
other person that's kind of attempted
they're all dead
they're all dead they just [ __ ] fell
off and died right they just there's
even
a one where there's this guy finally
climbed it with a parachute on just for
safety but that's considered cheating
because
free solo is all about not having backup
so he goes
he falls off and you see him and as he
was falling my nuts were shrinking i'm
like oh my god am i going to see this
guy fall to his death he pulls the chute
and he hovers and then the next clip is
hidden [ __ ] dead
so i think he tried again he's like oh
okay if i could do with the shoot then
the next time i could do without
a shoot but the point is like these guys
they hustle hard as [ __ ]
yeah so if you don't they don't value
their lives
or they just need more higher
stimulation true that [ __ ] dude
tie your dick to a people's mouth
[Music]
even your id is not accurate it's not
because yeah no one verified that
my weight was way way less than what i
weighed at that time
[Music]
that's a cute little video they said
that they're gonna be verifying it
because you have to upload a photo
of yourself near a commercial building
oh my god
they have this algorithm that figures
out like if you're telling the truth and
how tall
well you can't just do it next to a
building they have to do it next to like
a water bottle
or something you know something that
everybody everybody knows
the size of and then put your hand next
to it if you have tiny baby hands next
to you you already know you're [ __ ]
lying
a lot of men felt um
attacked what [ __ ] little [ __ ]
dude they're like
oh if men have to have a height
verification then women have to have a
weight verification too
then that ain't no problem and then so
they're just saying like how are you
doing
no problem [ __ ] and so
yeah all this like a whole bunch of men
were like oh so now body shaming
men now like now
if i have a guy and say that you got no
game i body shame them i'm just gonna
slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of them dude
it's like you don't get to use that
you don't get to use the whole body i
know that there is like male body
shaming per se
not really though the other side of it
is so much more worse
yeah so it's like it doesn't really
matter it's one percent versus like a
[ __ ] hundred and ten percent
it's like a person with allergies going
oh are you gonna handicap shame people
and also too i feel like the
counterbalance for men who are fat and
ugly is just money
you know so we actually have something
on our side where it's like
you're the fattest [ __ ] ugliest
bucktooth cross side i have five
billion dollars i will suck that dick
right now
that's what'll happen dude i'm talking
about for me
like if that's that's archaic i'm gonna
suck that dick
right now i feel like girls don't have
that like if a girl had an absorbent
amount of money
there's only a select amount of guys
that would be like [ __ ] what she looks
like i'm gonna go for that 100
i would five billion that's what i'm
saying though that's why you were a real
genius she had five million
dude if she had a dick the size of this
[ __ ] banana
bam swallowing it all no you wouldn't
five billion dollars a billion you get
it
i would change all your lives stacey i
just met you i would change your life
i assume that you're again i think i
would do it for five million dollars
five four five million i would do it for
one billion
girl one billion dollars man i could
of jesus christ himself for five billion
dollars
if i had to suck a dick for five billion
dollars for all you [ __ ] i
would do i would do it too and i think
you wouldn't even do it for five i think
you would do it for one
i would do it for ten dollars
who got ten dollars a billion billion
dollars everybody has a price everybody
has and it's way lower than five billion
dollars oh for sure it's a solid million
it's like three million and you'd be
like [ __ ] yeah i'd do it for a million
right now i
probably would too but let's you know
prostitution
it depends
depends no completion i'm good yes
anyway so tinder was saying
that there is only 14.5 of the us male
population that is actually six
and beyond six feet and beyond fourteen
percent
five percent oh that's small that is a
small person minority
yeah uh how tall right now uh people
people have said five eleven oh five
nine five twelve wait really
five nine yeah you know what short
people do too tracy
but they said that there are eighty
percent of males on tinder who are
claiming that they're over six feet
they all lie they all like three percent
exactly
oh my god that's so weird with like
people who are i want to say short
people people who are conscious about
their height they'll always do this
i'm a five ten two quarters like [ __ ]
nobody [ __ ] asks for the two quarters
dude nobody cares
what are you fight ten are you [ __ ]
five eleven why don't they lie
realistically like if you're five six i
think i have to pull a five seven maybe
i think i have a theory i think because
so many girls are so short like probably
your height how tall you're five four
four
so five four so if you tell a five four
girl like oh i'm six one six two six
three she might be like yeah he's just
really tall
you know but you tell a tall girl like
[ __ ] i got that unlocked like i know
how you are like when i see you yeah
yeah so i think most
women are shorter you know so a taller
woman is probably not going to be
on tinder that you know what i mean we
exist but i don't know it's just weird
like i think for shorter girls might be
easier to fool than a taller girl dude i
feel like girls do put a lot of emphasis
on heights we do and i don't know why i
wish it wasn't so important dude but
when you see a tall dude you're just
like damn
[Laughter]
i'm like damn though i don't see tall
damn i mean
i'm not attracted to all dudes no okay
wait wait wait no
i get it y'all in love and i love them
all my boyfriends before that though
really they were all sure
yeah what does that say about me the guy
before him was
was six feet and that was and that for
me i was just like
like it was cool but i don't know i i
just i think just mine
wants to look down on her man dude you
know
i want to crack the whip no but i think
now and maybe it is different you know
and maybe it's just like
preference or whatever but i don't know
it's just crazy like
i see a tall dude and that's
automatically more attractive
but that's just me you know i can only
speak for myself so by the way
this all turned out to be an april
fool's joke
and then we got to see all the [ __ ] ass
man complaining about some [ __ ]
trivial
acts good that was good but honestly
though i don't think that's a bad idea
but i think there's a reason i don't
think it should matter i don't think so
either
i don't because when you meet them
you're going to be like i think all the
dudes sweep out all the [ __ ]
phony i think all the dudes that came
out they should get [ __ ] certified now
yeah they just called tender
tender certification that's funny
i like that
[Music]
you